new tonight it could be the incentive
that ccsd needs to recruit new teachers
but some say it's discouraging to
existing ones starting teacher pay will
now be a little bit more than fifty
thousand dollars now the goal is to get
a competitive edge and to lure more
educators to the fourth largest district
in the country critics though of the
seven thousand dollar raise admitted
although it's a step in the right
direction retaining veteran teachers
should be more valuable than recruiting
new ones
we all know the district doesn't have
the 300 million dollars that it would
take
to raise all teachers salaries our pay
has been neglected our benefits are
declining and our working conditions are
increasingly hostile
that's not how you retain teachers
retention bonuses will be given to
administrators non-educators and school
police as well with the closure of
schools during the pandemic and rising
incidents of violence on school campuses
keeping teachers has been a challenge